Speaker 1: I have two clips that I'm going
to play for you here that are one very,
very significant in terms of what it suggests is
happening legally in Washington, D.C. right now
and to one which is just absolutely hilarious.
It's a sort of mike drop moment related to Matt
Gaetz and his alleged child sex trafficking.
The videos involve an individual named
Marc Short. Now, Marc Short was former vice
president Mike Pence's former chief of staff.
He, we have now learned, has been brought under
subpoena and testified before a Washington, D.C.,
federal grand jury investigating
January six. Why is this a big deal?
It's a big deal. I'm not quizzing you. I'll tell
you, I don't ask it rhetorically. It's a big deal
because as the January 6th House Committee has
been doing its work, we've been wondering aloud,
is the Department of Justice investigating any
or some or all of the things that we've learned
from the January six committee? Or are they
even seriously investigating at a higher level
the events of January 6th? We know that there
are hundreds of individual defendants for their
personal roles on January 6th. But there's a
broader question as to whether the bigger picture
of the way that Trump and the people around
him incited the riots is being investigated by
Merrick Garland. The fact that Marc Short was
under subpoena and appeared before a federal
grand jury in Washington, D.C., at least suggests
that the answer is yes. So the funny clip is the
second one. Let's look at this first. He didn't
say much, but this is a major confirmation.
Speaker 2: I can confirm that I did receive
a subpoena for the federal grand jury and I
comply with that subpoena. But under advice of
counsel, I really can't say much more than that.
That was my only appearance before the grand
jury. I'm not going to comment what others
on the team have had to testify or not regarding
subpoenas and what they've testified to.
Speaker 1: This suggests it doesn't prove, but
it certainly suggests. And what else might it
mean? It's hard to think of something else.
This indicates that the federal government,
the Justice Department, is now investigating
January 6th at a bigger and higher level than
simply individuals who were at the Capitol
on that day. That's a major, major thing.
Also during an interview with CNN, Short was asked
about Matt Gaetz's comments over the weekend,
and Short delivers an absolutely brutal takedown
of Gates. The look on CNN anchor Aaron Burnett's
face sort of says it all here. Check this out.
Speaker 2: Our America is proudly ultra maga.
Not some low energy roadside rhino safari. On that
note, let me just say what everybody here knows.
Mike Pence will never be
president. Nice guy. Not a leader.
Mark? Well, I don't know if Mike Pence will
run for president 2024, but I don't think Matt
Gaetz will have an impact on that. In fact, I'd be
surprised if he was still voting. It's more likely
he'll be in prison for child sex trafficking by
2024. And I'm actually surprised that Florida
law enforcement still allows him to speak
to teenage conferences like that. So I'm not
to worry about Matt Gaetz. Thanks.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Shocking that law
enforcement even allows Matt Gaetz against
around people under age 18. So listen.
Absolutely hilarious, perfectly delivered. And
in all seriousness, Matt Gaetz might get away
with absolutely nothing happening to him and no
consequences whatsoever for the alleged crimes
that he has been involved in. The question is what
the hell is taking so long? I actually remember
when I first learned that Matt Gaetz was under
investigation for child sex trafficking. It was
March of 2021, I remember, because it was my
first trip, sort of like in the COVID era. I
remember exactly where I was. I was about to go
out to the beach and I glanced at my phone and saw
Gates is now under investigation. And that was the
night that Gates appeared on Tucker Carlson's show
and gave that bizarre interview where he was
like, Tucker, you've met the woman supposedly
I trafficked. Remember? We went to dinner
and Tucker was like, I have no memory of that
whatsoever. Don't put me into this thing. That
was the start of it. That was now six months ago.
16 months ago. So is it is it unusual that it can
take this long for investigations to be done? No,
it's not unusual. Is it starting to get to the
point where it's reasonable to wonder what's
going on and are they even going to charge Gates
with anything? Yes, it is getting to that point.
So good for Marc Short for just saying what we're
all thinking. How is this guy even still around,
allowed around young girls, but absolutely
well-delivered and it's all great and everything.
But it is not obvious to me whatsoever that there
are actually going to be any consequences for Matt
Gaetz and of course these are alleged things that
he did. If the evidence doesn't show that he did
them, then he should not be charged. We this is
not a show where I demand people be charged for
things they didn't do. What we're aware of is that
Matt Gaetz, alleged coconspirator, certainly has
acknowledged doing a whole bunch of the stuff that
he and Gates are accused of. And so now it starts
to stretch our credulity when we say, well, so the
other guy did all this stuff and he's admitting
it, but we're supposed to believe Gates actually
wasn't involved in it. When there's that, it's
abundantly clear that they know each other and
that they were involved in this stuff together.
Starts to get hard to believe, but we will
follow it. And hopefully Marc Short is correct